because it's the lone star series it's
time for game one of three with jake
odorizzi on the mound who is in bounce
back mode today and that last start
against chicago we saw him just last
three and a third inning this is a
veteran we're talking about so he knows
exactly what to do to get himself right
knows his pitches very well knows his
stuff knows when he has a good feel
daniel lowe last time we saw the rangers
he was nate lowe but he's now going more
by the name nathaniel though you can
still call him nate if you want
ground ball towards euler a couple of
hops and yuli will take it himself and
jake oderizzi has two quick outs on four
pitches
and delivers a two-strike pitch swing
and a mess got him on a good splitter
down and in and odor is he needs just
seven pitches to complete a one two
three first and colby allard the
left-hander will be making the start for
the rangers start number 10 for him
it'll be his 20th appearance you can see
those 10 relief appearances they're good
eras had a little bit of bad luck with
the record about 4.06 for him so far
this year very nice 233 batting average
against for colby
one two
and that one
in the air back of second base ibanez
telling everybody it's mine
i'll make the catch and he does inning
is over a one two three for ali
[Music]
gallo you can see since the all-star
break over the last seven games just two
for 22 with 12 strikeouts does not have
an rbi during that stretch either
1-1
that's a ground ball softly hit right
side into the shift to his left correa
shortstop has it and throws out gallow
one away jonah heim will stand in swing
and a miss good morning good afternoon
and good night jonah high and finished
him off with a high fastball second
strikeout voter rizzy two out he's got a
great swing and missed fastball and
here's big kurt for his first big league
played appearance at round rock he hit
294 he had 17 home runs that was fourth
in the league 53 rbis that was second
and interestingly enough he had reverse
splits he hit well over 300 against
right-handed pitchers
3-2 pitch popped up altuve and correa
converge who wants it it will be carlos
who takes it as a two will always
have a good time with pop-ups in between
each other odorensi battles through the
second a walk one man left on base
tucker shoots one to right field gallow
will try and play it on a hop he
barehands it tucker will still go first
to third mile straw with a base hit to
right
left on left matchup with tucker at
third straw at first two outs in the
bottom of the second astros and rangers
are scoreless two balls two strikes two
outs two on the pitch he struck him out
swinging and joey gallo did indeed
save a run with that marvelous play down
the right field line
so altuve to the plate now
it will be the 81st consecutive inning
that the rangers have not held a lead
at the end of an inning
81.
that one lined off of kinder philippa's
glove and he'll recover quickly to get
the force out at second base
garcia held for a moment not sure
whether or not kinder philippa was going
to catch that
here's michael brantley brantley shoots
one to left field that is falling fast
and a diving attempt dahl can't come up
with it michael brantley with a base hit
and the astros will have runners on
first and second
base is loaded for alvarez and the first
pitch
is a liner and that's a base hit to
right center field altuve scores easily
everybody advances one base
on the line shot from alvarez the
astronauts lead one nothing
correa struck out looking as last time
up
he's due
broken back ground balls on the left
side holt's got it goes to second for
the force over to first not in time run
scored on the fielder's twice
it's two nothing
so runners on first and third now for
the astros for tucker who reached on an
error his last time up
astros lead two nothing
tucker drives one deep to right field
joey gallo all the way back that ball's
gone
kyle tucker
a three run home run into the astros
bullpen it's now a five to nothing game
allen had been trying to rush that
fastball up and into left-handed hitters
and tie him up and
kyle tucker fouled a couple off he gets
that fastball in but it's down in that
happy spot he barrels it up and goes
into launch mode
swinging a miss
strikeout number three for odorizzi two
away in the inning
rizzi will face jonah high
swing and a miss jake strolls off the
mound with a one two three striking out
heim for the second time odor rizzi with
four strikeouts through four
it's a two minute scoring position for
brantley he's one for two 2-0 pitch is a
check swing dribbler toward the mound he
comes home with it safe
great slide by robel garcia sliding to
the right of the plate reaching with his
left hand
to get the back of the plate and he
scores and the astros are up six nothing
probably just about the end of the line
for allard
facing guerrielle now
yuli hits a high fly ball plenty deep
enough to score altuve dahl and garcia
converge as david dahl who makes the
catch
a sac fly for the major league leader in
sac flies curiel picks up his 11th
sacrifice fly it is 7-0 astro
with two on and two outs here's a kiner
falefa two and one
and the ground ball hit on the right
side altuve to his left and it's off his
glove into right center field here comes
holt around third heading home and he
will score throw to third and safe at
third as ibanez as the ball comes out of
garcia's glove the rangers are on the
board and the astros lead 7-1 and here's
nathaniel lowe
and low hits it hard
out to center field that ball carries
well and all the way to the fence abania
is in easily kiner falefa scores easily
heading to third base is low and he's in
there with a two run triple
his second triple of the season
and he makes it a 7-3 ball game rangers
trailing the astros 7-3 be the third
major league at bat for curtis terry the
dh and his major league debut has popped
up and struck out
grounds one towards third robel garcia
to his left
make the play across for out number one
brandon belak has base five batters and
retired all five
three two pitch set into center field
mile straw backs up a few steps and
he'll put it away brandon belaff two and
a third shutout innings
nice job out of the bullpen for the
astros brandon bilac who had a great
outing tonight elac faced eight batters
retired seven of them brandon would be
in line to get the win in this 7-3 game
a two-out rally for the rangers down 7-3
in the eighth inning and david dahl will
be the batter here's the 1-0
and that skied in the shallow center
going back correa three steps into the
outfield grass behind second puts it
away and the inning is over
so the rangers get a couple of two out
base runners but stranded both
astros trying to close this one out the
opening game of this three-game series
in the lone star series
curtis terry the dh in his major league
debut is 0 for three a pop up a
strikeout in a groundout
wow
javier looking strong getting curtis
terry on three pitches picking up a
strikeout for the first out of the night
javier
doing a good job throwing six of seven
strikes he's ahead of a banya's one and
two
he got him
ball game over astros win it seven to
three they improve at 20 games over
7-0 on the season against the rangers
here at home